so unlike a normal photograph a digital
image is made up of pixels small
individual locations of certain color or
a certain level of grayscale intensity
and we store that in memory as a
basically a very long list and along
with other information like the width
and the height of the image we can then
access those pixels and determine what
color they are and what we commend you
other things like apply our filters or
compile them into a video or something
like that so to keep it simple to begin
with for a demonstration we'll talk only
about uncompressed images already loaded
into memory so rather than a specific
file format like like a gif file or a
BMP file we'll talk about them some
other time we'll talk just about
uncompressed images in memory how they
are stored and how we use them usually
memory is a contiguous block so it's one
long line and so it's very helpful to us
to represent two-dimensional images as
actually a very long line of data so
what we usually start with of an image
is some kind of header and that will
tell us what the image file format is
how wide it is how tall it is and if
there's any other information like exif
data or you know camera calibration data
that sort of thing will be included in
there and then we essentially have a
very very long list of pixels so we
start here and this point here will be
our first row of our image and we'll
have a pixel here we'll call pixel one
and then we'll have another pixel here
pixel two and how long each of these
pixels is in memory will depend on the
type of image we're looking at so if
we're doing let's say a two by two image
then I image will look a bit like this
when it's finished pixel one two three
and four so this is our image it's two
pixels high and two pixels wide and so
in our actual memory we have our header
and then we have the first pixel on the
second pixel so that's row one and then
we might have some padding data that we
won't worry too much about that depends
on the file format and then we'll just
go on straight onto our second row so we
have pixel three and pixel four and that
is essentially our image stored in
memory and then because we know how wide
and how high the images we can index
these directly so we can say that if
this is our stride which is 1 + 2 + P
then we can go one stride along to get
to the next row and then two strides
long to get to the next row and so on
and we can read the
like that so that's what an image looks
like on a very basic level each of these
pixels represent some amount of memory
how much that is depends on the type of
image that we're looking at so if it's a
grayscale image generally speaking
there'll be less then were used than if
it's an RGB image RGB images are by far
the most common most you know most
images that we capture of RGB an RGB is
red green yes Meg green and blue and
they represent the primary colors that
we detect in our eyes so that's that's
why it's helpful to think of a couple of
extra properties of our image that we
look at is the bit depth and that is how
many bits how many notes and ones
represent each individual element of
color or gray and a number of channels
per pixel so that in an RGB image that
might be 3 or it might be 4 if it's an
RGB alpha image this alpha is
transparency so a pixel will have a
number of channels so let's say C in
this case is 3 so for RG and B and then
a bit depth is usually 8 you can get bit
depths ranging from 1 which was just an
auteur one sort of pixel a diver on or
off up to 16 maybe 32 that's very high
just like with normal binary encoding
the more bits you use per pixel and per
color channel the more information you
can hold so 8 is a maximum level of 255
for a byte and so in this case we have
three channels RG and B each of which
can be somewhere from naught to 255 what
those represent so 0 would be what black
yet there will be none of that color at
all and 255 would be the most of that
color but the cameras seen bearing in
mind that sample of posting will have
taken place because of ISO and things
like this and so all that you do when
you increase in a bit depth is giving
more different increments image passing
yes that's exactly right it's unlikely
but you would use it to show even
brighter red because usually 255 would
mean as as red as you could get let's
say so you would just have a finer range
of colors in between for most general
purpose use a bit deep of 8 is perfectly
adequate because you've got three
different color channels doing that so
that's that's perfectly ample so another
common file format would be an 8 bits
per pixel grayscale image so if you go
into an image processing package and you
take your color image and you convert it
to grayscale what it usually does is
some averaging of the three colour
channels and then a much more memory
efficient way of storing that would be
to represent it as gray so in that case
we have our header information and then
we literally have pixel 1 which will
just be a grayscale value from naught to
255 so we'll have a bite here which is
pixel 1 and a byte here which is pixel 2
and a byte here which is pixel 3 and
each of those only takes up one byte
rather than three or four for a normal
RGB image and that's why RGB images are
generally much larger so alpha is very
common when you're doing image editing
because it might be useful for a sort of
combination of layers above other layers
and things like this it's obviously not
very common in normal photographs
because canva can't measure transparency
that wouldn't make much sense but in
general 32-bit images that is four
channels per pixel
it's very common even when we're not
using the Alpha so you might find that
your digital camera produces a 32 bit
per pixel four channel image even though
it doesn't actually output transparency
and that alpha is just held as a padding
byte and that way we can reckon index
each of our pixels in integer terms and
it makes it much more much simpler to do
the the mathematics of getting to a
certain pixel and doing something with
it if this is our header and this is our
color image here then what in fact p1 is
is a row of RGB and then met possibly an
alpha channel possibly something erb it
doesn't do anything so we'd have the red
here the green blue and this X here
which may be an alpha channel may not be
and each of these in an 8-bit image will
be 8 bits long so that's one byte so
this is eight bits long this is eight
this is eight and this is eight here and
then so the total size of this pixel is
32 bits and that's what 32 bit image is
now 32 happens to be on a lot of
computer architectures the size with
integer or at least if it isn't you can
get a 32 bit integer very easily and
that allows us to jump to a specific
pixel somewhere in our image so the
height of our image is useful for
knowing when we're going to go off the
end of the image and into some other
memory but in terms of indexing pixels
we don't use it what we use is something
called a stride which is the width of a
row of an image
bearing in mind any padding and that
depends on the file format so so so
would you be fair to say that the height
of the image is how many strides we've
got that's exactly right yes but of
course you're looking at a single block
of memory and if your operating system
isn't being careful
you want to make sure you don't go off
the end if we know what our stride is
here and that will be some width in
bytes of our image including any padding
and then we know we have enable X and a
verbal eye that tell us which pixel we
want then where we want to go to is the
very beginning of our image plus a
certain number of rows based on our Y
plus a certain number of pixels based on
our X so the actual formula is the pixel
we want is y times our stride plus X and
that will take us through a certain
amount of rows of data and straight to
the to the row we want and then to the
pixel we want and so this formula we can
use to jump straight to the pixel we
want and they're using some slightly
more advanced programming and bit
shifting we can obtain the actual RGB
data out of that integer and then we can
do things to it we could average them to
make it a grayscale image or we could
blur them or we could add an alpha
channel if we were doing some kind of
more complicated image editing something
like that OCR
I'm using image manipulation to make
these computer file videos all the time
if I'm selecting a pixel in Photoshop
and decided to change it some why this
is what's going on this is exactly
what's going on behind the scenes here
so it will if you select an individual
pixel it'll know the X&Y location you'll
know how that image is stored in a being
row in memory and it will index that
location and alter the RGB values for
you which makes it a lot easier if we
want to turn these into pixels all we
need to do is to look by the nearby
pixels that have the color we're looking
for and interpolate that value so in
this case we don't have a green value
here but we know what this green value
is and we know what this green value is